C'est l'heure de l'épisode 5
la dernière fois on a fini sur la chute tragique de Trico et de l'enfant
Ça nous a mis un peu en PLS, on va pas se mentir
mais, c'est sûr ils sont vivants... J'espère
C'est parti !
OUI!...
Lui il est vivant
Mais Trico mec, c'est Trico surtout qu'on veut voir
T'affole pas!
Tu vas faire péter la brindille !
euuuuuuh
OH j'peux l'controler là ?
Ouais...le but c'est qu'elle se casse je pense de toute manière
OH Y'A TRICO EN BAS !
Y'A TRICO EN BAS !
Il va bien!
Comment je fais pour descendre ?
Trico aide moi !
Je suis bloqué !
*ordre*
C'est bon il m'a vu !
Il va pouvoir m'aider vous pensez ?
Tu m'aides, Trico ?
Vas-y va sur le pilier aide-moi mon grand !
Nice!
Faudrait que tu sautes dans les buissons et que tu m'attrapes...
Oh oui !
Ça y est, tu vas m'aider ?
Tu viens m'aider ?
Tu me récupères ?
Oh putain, merde...
aaaaah
T'as tenté...bien joué mon grand !
Bien joué (3X)
Euh... on va trouver une solution mon grand !
Ah merde !
OH !
Il a tenté quelque chose ?
OH OUI !
IL S'EST ACCROCHÉ AUX BRANCHES !
TRICO ! *rires*
Ah la queue !
Fais péter la queue ! Elle est où la queue ?
Allez, on est pas loin !
Pousse la un peu !
OUI ! C'est bon !
MERCI TRICO !
Il a fait balancer sa queue, il est trop malin !
Eh ben mon grand...
Ah c'était...
Ah tu t'étais mis au dessus, juste là OK...
Purée, on a fait une belle chute mon gars !
On est tombés de tellement haut !
C'est incroyable qu'on soit encore en vie !
Bon tu me diras qu'on s'était pris des belles chutes avec l'enfant...Heu....
Aussi, hein ?
Alors me revoila sur ton dos, qu'est-ce qu'on fait une fois qu'on est là ?
On va redescendre, hein ?
Ouais ! Ouais ouais ouais...
Très bien mon grand !
Vas-y, vas-y descends, hein ?
Bah ouais y'a rien là-haut
Woaw ! Alors comment... Ah y'a des papillons !
Y'a d'la bouffe pas loin pour toi !
Alors attend, voyons voir ce qu'il y a à faire... T'as trouvé la bouffe ?
Ah non t'es attiré...
Oh mais nan !
Mais nan mon gars mais on est retournés mais tellement loin !
C'était dans l'épisode où...
Où on commençait à sauter
sur le dos de Trico j'crois...
Oh lalalala... Putain mon gars !
Ouais je sais pas comment...tu peux pas venir la ?
Tu peux pas pousser la grille ?
Ok
sauf que notre tour
"Natoo"
Il a dit "j'adore les vidéos de Natoo"...
J'suis en train de repérer...Peut-être par là...
Va falloir le relancer ça c'est sûr !
Pour finalement arriver là...
Ouais va falloir se démerder pour que le tonneau arrive là et qu'on refasse le tour comme ça.
Le jeter là pour le récupérer là et l'envoyer... ok ouais j'pense c'est ça, ok...
Hop là j'le reprends direct !
Voiiiila
Ça me permet de passer ensuite soit faut l'envoyer là soit faut l'envoyer...
là-bas directement mais j'y crois pas trop trop...
J'aurais plus dit là d'abord...
Nice !
J'le reprends...
Ok
C'est marrant ces énigmes au tonneau
mais bon on se souvient comment j'avais ragé comme un c****** dans la...
*rires* dans l'épisode d'avant
mais en même temps, y'avait trop de hasard, j'avais trop pas de chance
Hop! Je le reprends, on est bon
Et là, je peux l'envoyer là-bas directement
Je pense ouais...Allez foire pas là s'il te plaît Triii....
Trico..?! N'importe quoi, c'est pas toi Trico mais c'est pas grave
Ok, c'est bon! Et maintenant..On peut directement lui amener
T'attrapes ?! Direct dans la gueule ?
Ah oui..T'es blessé à un oeil??
Pourquoi tu fermes un oeil? Merde..
Chope!
*rires* Ah nan.. t'as pas voulu
Ah il y a un levier ici tiens
Je sais pas trop où on peut aller là Trico, tu saurais m'aider ou pas?
Ouais vas-y, vas-y fais ton saut!
J'suis sur toi vas-y tu peux y aller
Yes
Ohhhhh ! Redescends !
Tu vois bien que sans toi j'suis perdu bébé *rires*
Voila désolé
Jte gache ton énergie pour rien mon gars mais
Franchement tu pars tellement vite en même temps tu m'envoies euhh, 7G dans la gueule quand tu sautes
yaaaa....!
C'est bon
Oh put**! J'ai bien failli pas tenir là non plus
Alors.. Donc là c'est là où on était au début
tu vas re sauter c'est ça ? Bon je reste accroché alors
Je vais sur le côté accroché
Yes
Ensuite quand t'es là on fait quoi ?
Vas-y j'te laisse gérer hein, c'est ton délire là Trico
Ah t'as trouvé vas-y.
Y'a un petit trou dans le mur effectivement
Ok on est bon wouuuw
nous revoilà, dehors
On a perdu tellement de hauteur Trico à cause de l'autre bête
Vas-y t'y vas, ouais...
Ah j'te laisse gérer hein (rire)
Là on est en pilote automatique Trico
Ouais au top!
Saute! allez vas-y là haut
WOW!
Ok on y est...
Et maintenant...
*Cri de surprise*
Oh les bata*** (x2)
Ils ont des shields, ils ont des boucliers
Faits de la matière et de la forme que Trico déteste...
Rho put***
Faut que je descende là en tout cas c'est sûr
Ahh, c'est bon ok...
On y est, on va pouvoir y aller
par ici..
Et comment on fait ? Faut qu'on les attire ?!
Pour que leurs boucliers se cassent ?
Ah put** j'me demande comment on va faire
Parce que habituellement il y a que le verre il y a pas les mecs qui peuvent nous péter la gueule
Le verre il est tout seul il se défend pas
Là, c'est sous forme de bouclier donc il y a un mec qui le tient
Donc on est dans le caca
Là on est en train de passer dessous en fait, ouais les gardes sont juste de l'autre coté
Trico il est là
Il est en train de bader en regardant ces put** de boucliers mon gars
Hop, on va passer par là
Ouais c'est en face hein
Rah j'aime trop la musique !
Quand il y a du danger la musique elle est folle !
Elle est tellement bien mec !
J'aime trop
On va faire le tour, ouais on va faire le tour
Ah on peut rentrer par là quand même
Ah put*n il y a des gardes juste là mec c'est chaud
De toutes manière on va devoir engager une course pousuite c'est sûr
Et peut être qu'il faut que je les ...
Que je les attire
Les mecs avec les boucliers je parle
Comme ça Trico pourra venir
Oh bah voilà t'façon je me suis chié dessus donc euh ...
Ok maintenant je peux esquiver
Oh nan !
Oh put**** je fais n'importe quoi
Eh, lâche moi ! ça dégage !
Ok...
Ouais ok il sont nombreux, ouais c'est bien ce que je pense
Faut que je les attire
Oh ouais maintenant je peux faire tomber les mecs, ok!
Trico j'ai besoin d'aide! Fais le saut!
Trico vite!!
Nan! J'ai pas résisté!
Trico!!
Oooooooh!!
oh il les a rekt
oh ça y est il les a rekt
Il les a démolis. Moi je monte sur lui comme ça je suis en sécurité
Et je vais le caresser pour le calmer.
Allez calme toi Trico. C'est bon, c'est bon, c'est bon...
On se calme
On se calme, on se calme!
Ok tu casses la caméra, tu casses la caméra...*rires*
C'est bon mon grand, on l'a fait!
Alors!
On va où maintenant?
Ici on a une grille... Ah y a que moi qui peux passer regarde il manque des barreaux!
Ok
Bon moi je peux passer pas toi, mais bon, je vais t'ouvrir bien évidement
Tu vas me rejoindre très très vite tu t'en doutes!
Ah ben regarde!
Regarde à quoi il servait le trou!
C'est spécialement pour toi
On sent le Fail attention... 3-2-1, le Fail
*rires*
Allez tiens !
Mange, t'as besoin de forces là
T'as carry la game, mets toi bien
Pendant ce temps là je vais voir les chemins possibles... Ben voilà
C'est celui là
Allez on y va Trico!
C'est parti!
A gauche y a rien et à droite...
hola attend
Mec c'est des gardes, c'est quoi?
C'est pas des gardes?!
Bon ben Trico, en tout cas tu vas devoir m'amener juste là-haut toi
Comme tu peux le voir j'ai besoin de toi pour aller là
Yep!
Waouh!
Et là on a du choix
Oh put***!
Ben juste là-haut en fait, là en face. Vas-y
Nickel!
Vas y mon grand, fonce!
Yes!
Le dernier
Parfait
Donc là, à mon avis, déjà j'y vais tout de suite mais...
Aïe
Ouais
y a une échelle, je pense qu'elle est pas là pour rien
Voilà
Attends j'vais t'ouvrir, j'vais t'ouvrir, j'vais t'ouvrir...
Je te réouvre ça
Comme ça toi tu passes, voilà, et moi je peux passer entre les barreaux
Hop là!
Il est où?
Il est où le c**?
Trico?
Ah put***, il est descendu en bas, y a une sorte de potion
Mer**!
Euh...
Oh put***...
Ok, ça va, si je tombe de très haut mais sur Trico ça va
Et il nous a sauvé 100 000 fois Trico mon gars!
Alors c'est sur un rail, je crois qu'on va pouvoir le tirer
Ouais, c'est ça on peut le tirer
On va de ce pas le tirer
Ok, on est bien là!
On peut pas le pousser?
Si on peut le pousser, de l'autre côté
Je rallume la lumière tout en poussant, c'est compliqué!
*bruit d'effort*
Aaaaah ok, regardez y a deux rails
Y a deux rails, il doit y avoir un truc à activer quelque part
Et là-haut y a un truc auquel je pense que je suis censé accéder
Ca m'amènerait derrière les grilles et ça me permettrait de déclencher ce levier
Ouais!
Alors on y retourne
Ok c'est fait maintenant il faut vite que je monte sur Trico
Voilà!
On a accédé au truc, on va pouvoir aller activer le levier qui est là-bas
Je sais pas encore à quoi il sert, mais peut-être que ça change l'aiguillage?
Yata!
Yes! Bingo!
Let's go
Ca va se casser et il va y en avoir par terre, vous pensez?
Oh put***...
pau
En plus ça bouche le trou, quoi!
Il peut pas me rejoindre!
Holy Shit...
Je vais devoir voler
euh, je vais devoir nager, pardon, n'importe quoi
Euh j'vais devoir me servir de ce truc comme d'un flotteur je suppose ?
Il est juste au-dessus regardez, on le voit Trico
Euh je vais devoir me servir de ça pour atteindre quelque chose mais quoi ?
Tu veux pas m'aider euh... laisser pendre ta queue comme tu fais à chaque fois par put*** de miracle ?
A tout hasard ?
Fais pendre ta put** de queue !
Ah peut-être qu'il faut le faire sauter ?
Comme ça il va casser le truc ?
Ouais, regardez les planches !
Vas-y saute ! Casse... casse le bois !
Ouais... ouais...
Ouais nickel !
ouais...
Allez Trico steuplait
Ah bah voilà !
Putain ya la queue là !
Allez vas-y on y va !
Yata !
Ah put** j'ai jamais été aussi content de retrouver ta queue !
Nice !
Merci mon pote !
Bon bah du coup on continue
Alors du coup attends on venait de là-bas
et il faut continuer vers là-bas !
Regarde Trico c'est par là
let's gooo
tu vas devoir faire un putain de saut
viens ! sois pas timide
vas y t'y vas?!
tu peux le faire le saut
tu veux aller là haut ? Ah d'accord, ok, j'ai compris
vas-y vas-y
ouais.... yes
pouuuuua
Faut encore aller au dessus là
yes
nickel
pourquoi? pourquoi y a une musique comme ça?
oh putain.. vas-y défonce-les trico
défonce-les ! allez
saccage-le
c'est bien ! nickel ! parfait !
ok, il est calmé
on va pouvoir avancer mon cher Trico
alors par où on va ? est ce qu'il faut qu'on aille plutôt vers la lumière?
ouuuh c'est quoi cet endroit ? attends c'est une porte ça? je peux l'ouvrir?
on dirait un wagon de train... mais non c'est juste une porte, bizarre
vers ici
c'est le dehors
on va pas y faire grand chose
ah putain ! il est mal encore, il faut que je trouve de la bouffe
merde.. et bah par là hein tout simplement.. j'avais pas vu
alors comment faire pour ramener ce tonneau
a mon avis il faut coller ça au trou
et mettre, et envoyer le tonneau dessus
parfait!
putain je suis aveugle hein je vise carrément à droite
oh il est beau celui la ! aaaah non
j'aurais dû coller la truc... oh bas non je suis à fond
en fait je peux pas faire mieux
bon sinon il y a une autre caisse
mais à quoi elle peut servir? a rien, elle sert à rien
ah si ok d'accord j'ai compris
les deux servent. on va la coller à l'autre comme ça il y aura plus de longueur et le tonneau ne tombera pas de l'autre côté
ok
on a à peu près bon
lancé numéro 1
ooooh
mais qui l'eut cru ?!
tiens poto
c'est pour toi !
ouf ! maintenant on va pouvoir s'en aller
ah il est content, quand il se remue comme ça c'est qu'il est heureux
en gros trico, là tu vas devoir sauter dans le trou qui est là
voiiiila
vas-y ramène-toi, ramène-toi, ramène-toi
et là tu vas sauter là haut, tu vois très bien de quoi je parle trico
voila là haut exactement, tu as tout compris
allez mon gars
nice !
alors ! je vais voir comment on va faire pour te ramener avec moi, ne t'en fais pas !
oh putain...
ça promet
si je ne meurs pas, je vais essayer de ne pas mourir
est-ce qu'il faut que j'aille de l'autre côté ou est ce qu'il faut que je descende sur ce toit là?
ça n'a pas de sens d'aller de l'autre côté, je pense qu'il faut aller là bas, hein
ouais, il faut traverser ça
mais Trico, il peut pas nous suivre là...
merde putain
et c'est bel et bien une sorte de conduit de train hein, vous avez vu !
ça ressemble à un train
putain j'avais même pas vu qu'il y avait un trou mon gars
Tri.......
oh putain... WOOOOH
oh putain j'ai sauté ! TRICO
AAAAH TRICO
ça fait vraiment peur... pardon
waaah putain
oh je suis foutu...
faut soulever ça, vite, vite, vite, vite, vite
oh non....
c'est horrible, si près du but
OOOH
nooon
yes ! cette fois c'est bon
c'est qu'on avait sauté trop tôt tout à l'heure
ok retourne là haut
ok nickel putain,  merci Trico, mon gars pour la millième fois tu me sauves la vie, c'est juste incroyable
oooh dis donc
oh bah !
qu'est ce que tu fais?
c'est nouveau ça mon gars?!
Tu veux sauter là bas ?
ouais vas y ça me va hein! Sur la montagne ?
ouuaaais, enchaîne vite par contre parce que j'ai pas envie de glisser
remarque il a des grosses griffes
Oh putain on dirait l'entrée d'un boss ça là
on dirait qu'on vas tomber nez à nez dans une arène
Face à l'autre Trico
Ah ça va se péter ça
Matez des Let's Play sur YouTube j'suis sûr ça arrive pas ça
Ah bah voilà du coup on spawn là directement
ça va plus vite, très bien
Putain Trico
Tu nous as sauvé pas mal de fois
mais tu nous as tué pas mal de fois
Oh putain mec c'est une arène
C'est vraiment une arène
Il y a pas de vitres qui fait peur à Trico ?
Bon ben Trico vas y faut y aller
Ah ils vont avoir des bouclier je vais devoir l'aider je pense
Ok vite faut que je descende faut que je descende
vite vite vite vite il y a encore des boucliers là bas
Barre-toi !
Oh le bâtard !
Hop là c'est bon
Cassez-vous
Vas y baise les vite Trico pendant qu'il y a plus le bouclier
Il vas essayer de le reprendre !
Casse-toi !
C'est bon vas y baise le !
Vas y vas y tue le vite
tue le vite avant qu'il le reprenne Trico !
C'est boooon, nice mon gars
Tu l'as explosé
Il est encore vivant, ils sont plus résistants ceux avec les boucliers
et le petit dernier
Merci mon gaaars
Alors maintenant qu'on est là qu'est ce qu'on fait mon ami ?
Ya des papillons... Doit y avoir de la bouffe.
Attends, je vais monter de l'autre côté voir
Regaaaarde, regarde comme j'ai vu juste
C'est pour toi Trico
*chuchote* comme ça c'est fait
Alors comment on peut sortir d'ici par contre ?
Euuh...
Qu'est-ce t'as fait ?
T'as touché à quoi là ?
Qu'est ce t'as fait Trico ?
Là haut... Y a des trous... Et là y a que des grilles...
Ah ! Ouais vas y vas y vas y vas y !
Fais ça mon gars c'est bien
Ouais !
Yes !
Merci mon gars
'tain heureusement qu'il a c'côté *s'interrompt* Merde
Heureus'ment qu'il a c'côté joueur hein
Qu'eeest-ce qu'est qu'ce truc
J'vais l'mettre en plein milieu d'la lumière
En plein milieu de la pièce, Ah mais ça va être pour atteindre la grille là haut
Pousse toi Trico ! Ah il regarde en haut, c'est sûr c'est ça on va se faire catapulter
voilà tu vois ça se bascule mon gars, tu comprends ?
Mais oui tu comprends t'es pas du tout con toi
Vas-y appuie un grand coup dessus
Bam un gros coup de patte !
Vas-y ouais !
Trop cool mon gars ! Oh trop bien
c'était très très bien
ça a beaucoup plu
Euh ah bah voilà un petit levier tiens
je sais pas trop comment j'vais pouvoir te libérer mais...
On va se démerder Trico
Ok une grille qui s'ouvre, ah bah ya deux **tain de leviers d'accord
J'arrive Trico, je t'entends coiner là ça va
voilà
c'est quoi ça c'est un truc à... ah j'ai cru que c'était un truc à bouffer à lui donner
Il va... il peut passer en bas là ou pas Trico ?
Voilà là faut qu'il saute
Viens là, viens là en sautant mon grand
Oui me regarde pas comme ça t'as très bien
compris
Il va venir
Voilà et maintenant on va accéder à
l'autre côté en fait
Par ici
et quand on sera là, peut-être au-dessus
Non pas grand chose non plus
Bon il avance doucement mais sûrement, peut-être sur le toit là bas
Mais là bas ya juste une grille fermée
Ya peut-être un moyen de l'ouvrir
et sauter... ah bah là haut ! Il va sauter là haut
Tu vas là haut, allez allez allez allez voilà tu regardes déjà c'est que tu sais qu'il faut y aller
Attention ça va être le saut
voilà tu vois quand tu veux
On a atterri dans une petite grotte
Avec un fond d'eau, normalement ça fait pas peur à Trico les fonds d'eau Mais bon
On est jamais à l'abri d'une surprise
et ici un baril oui ! Ah il a pas perdu de
temps
Par où on peut passer ici Trico ?
Ah bah là haut !
allez c'est trouvé , tu me mets bien tu sautes là haut, 3 2 1
On peut mieux faire sur la synchro *rire*
Ok on est au top
merci mon gars ! Alors par où j'peux aller ici
Tu m'expliques Trico
Comment j'fais... Oh ! Oooooh
ok yolo
y a pas 36 solutions, Trico let's gooooo
Whou ! Ah j'peux plonger maintenant ?! Mais oui !
J'peux plonger mon gars
J'peux plonger jusqu'où ?
**tain ça a l'air carrément profond là
Ah non ok je peux pas aller plus bas que ça
On peut passer juste là dessous à mon avis
Si on vient d'apprendre à plonger...
c'est sûrement parce qu'on doit plonger
pour passer à la suite, pour
moi c'est là clairement
C'est sûr ya un levier de l'autre côté, c'est là mon gars vas-y
Un peu plus bas en bas en bas
Là haut ya un truc que j'ai raté
ben voilà allez
allez allez allez ça s'est fait on en parle
plus
Allez, ah t'as vu dès qu'il a plus de souffle il fait moins le malin
Vas-y remonte ! Ah c'est bon pardon
Chui en train de paniquer pour lui
Hey Trico, tu couines tu descends mec hein tu l'as déjà fait je sais que t'en es
capable donc tu vas pas me prendre pour un con hein
qu'est-ce que ça a ouvert ?
la porte, ça sert à quoi ? Tricoooo
Tu sautes je te regarde
Il va y aller (x2)
Il se chauffe là, OH ! Whaaa
**tain ! Respect mon pote !
C'est bien mon grand allez petite caresse, donc je crois que ça a ouvert la grille
donc va falloir qu'on plonge Trico
Tu me suis si je plonge ?
Ouais tu me suis... vas-y vas-y faut aller là bas, je sais que t'as pas envie mais
va falloir qu'on plonge mon gars, tu peux plonger toi aussi non ?
Whoooooo
WOUHOU !
Il passe dans le trou ! On est au top !
Oh **tain donc il peut bien plonger lui aussi, oh ah ouais il va beaucoup plus profond et beaucoup
plus vite quoi ! **tain il me fait confiance hein
YEAH !
Bien joué !
**tain on l'a fait mec, trop cool !
Vas-y vas au sec, sèche toi
Bon, vers là bas je suppose en dessous la grille encore allez on va faire ça
Bingoo ! J'ai plongé et comme promis regardez
Comment ça je peux pas atteindre ça ?
WTF !
L'échelle est cassée !
Holy sh*t !
J'ai fait tout ça pour rien, fais genre une grosse bombe
comme ça dans l'eau ça, comme ça peut-être que je vais m'envoler comme avec la catapulte...
un geyser !
Ok il va le faire
Ca a marché !
Il a sauté et ça a fait une
**tain de vague mon gars ! J'ai pu atteindre le levier fantastique !
Trico maintenant on va voyager ensemble mon amour, allez vas-y fais moi rêver
YIIHII ! Allez on y va ! on va dans le trou et on fait ça vite parce que j'ai de vie illimitée non plus
Mais bon là je vois que tu donnes tout ce que tu peux et c'est très bien
On y va!
Euuuuh...
Attends je vais crever là
Oh merde dans quoi je nous ai embarqués?
Trico ?
Vite
Non!
Mais non!
Oh le bad !
Et ben voilà fin de ce cinquième
ou sixième épisode, je sais même plus
tellement je suis bouleversé *rire*  n'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous a plu
comme d'habitude et on se retrouve très vite pour le prochain
plus que 2 ou 3 épisodes
et c'est la fin du Let's Play :(
Et ben écoutez j'ai hâte qu'on fasse là suite ensemble
Merci d'avoir regardé et à très bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo, portez vous bien ciao tout le monde
PEACE !